that way like this I got like it's so
funny cuz I saw him do that and I went I
went yeah and I closed my fists and as I
was taking a picture I'll go why are you
closing your fist Brian well I just lost
I don't know what do with my hands I
went I'm gonna do this too and I was
like if if Brennan sees this it's gonna
be the most embarrassing facade because
our fans are like but can you believe
Callens doing this I made a fist in our
picture and I want to put on our pitch
meaning I would never allow the fan in
that standard I took a picture in San
Jose and somehow people tagged that
don't that is like a fight I don't I
didn't mean it my hand and then this is
the other prong when we know what off
air you keep telling about your boxing
yeah I can't
hey hold on hold on yeah I can't
emphasize enough
my nose is sure I will I would watch my
toes not you know hey tender tender
boxes there rather you share your wife's
dreams with me at night than your boxing
but come on dude my right I would rather
you tell me your wives okay what
Amanda's day was like I'm working body
now like I'm learning how to get low and
look and and the Bears tag me they're
like can you believe you made a fist I
make other people make this wider
semi-fixed ah that's what happens when
you train an 8k and you're around
fighters all of a sudden if you're there
and then you're around a bunch of guys
for making a and they come to your show
no sand you're like you know what I'm
friends with fighter that guys making a
bit what why am I doing this
I knew all right the minute I did I had
your face to the rest of our friends who
are gonna despise it - yeah - Lea Rogan
senator - Lea you saw that that's just
all tax that he sent me do Lea honor on
he gets so mad when I [ __ ] remember
they can't fix ya that you can hear it
though it's really funny did you guys
had been live for like five minutes
yeah I know all right cool he's in aa
stay there
this is Delino mad on social media
rolling around [ __ ] your Shh you're
50 you don't need to rolled around with
these young guys my age why are you
talking like that because ya century
epithets rude Oh
so find the exit so silly
um it's a little no speaking of dramatic
my son is very dramatic this my son this
morning made me laugh so hard he's
sitting there eating breakfast he's
going like this smacking his legs I know
what's up and he goes uh no I go honey
you guys don't have a whole lot of power
in my legs really I may not have to I
may not be able to go to school that's
all they're really yeah
don't have a lot of power in my legs so
I think I'm gonna sit home at school
well you're not you're not but thank you
don't give him the day off my my so easy
get the day off when I was a kid now
let's so much yeah I don't have a lot of
power in my legs smack of Italy that's
something I would do hey we've changed
cuz we what we we white truffle now
who's white truffle certified unique you
guys need three rights acres were alive
we are live we're live it's our first
live fire in the kid yeah it's kind of
exciting but um you know what we we know
you're right we we had on trial I
thought we had a white truffle fleeced
if you haven't ruffled up we Trump a
hell out powerful they shaved a mondo r1
Gila ice cream can I be honest yeah it
was too much yeah the vanilla ice cream
is one step too far
like we we had like a five course meal
there was white truffles on every how
about that steak though it's good the
pasta is what you want to go there for
that's where you paused is the
moneymaker
pastas the moneymaker the moneymaker you
real quick you eat that many white
truffles [ __ ] pants yeah it's a bad
idea
yeah I will can't have a horse I woke up
in the night and threw up yeah you can't
eat here
because you know what it is it's that
it's this phonemes it's the cheese the
creams and all the then all that not
[ __ ] with cheese and cream salt onion
it's the truffles yeah the truffles you
can't have that many we went a little
overboard with the truffles mmm
we ate we have truffle crazy weird
shuffle crazy $1,500 worth I didn't pay
that but we we probably if you were
charged regular prices apply what it
cost us $1,500 worth of why you want
truffle crazy
we went truffle craze too much truffle
wait yeah well I did not feel good no no
you can't eat em any cuz it's a fungus
that lives under the ground six feet
under great sense yeah pigs I mean you
see it but it's a good experience though
and it smells like nothing you've ever
smelled in a way right so is like my
kids feet yeah after he's done playing
yeah outside yeah it smells like guys
with some it smell no I'm not really
shitty smells like it like yeah like a
fungus like like a dirty song mmm-hmm
like a dirty Jim saw shave that on your
so strange man it's a delicious meal but
too many truffles delicious meal yeah a
little too much I don't know if I've had
black don't want black truffles now I
got that I got you covered on that those
are a little easier to get a little
easier to get into lish got you covered
that in the light well there's nothing
quite senior you're paying for that
unique flavor where you go oh this
smells and tastes like nothing I've ever
had that's that's kind of what you're
doing and then but you can't go crazy I
feel like this I feel like there's some
cheese that can compete with a white
truffle
I get nice cheese beautiful shaved
cheese imbue smells like that not as
expense I don't entirely disagree I
don't entirely disagree I've had
cheese's it'll change your whole [ __ ]
life oh right I mean sometimes cheese so
I went to my friend's place and they had
some cheese's out and I went what what
is that place there's actually a girl oh
it's off Montana
kind of about 7th of Montana it's a nice
stinks and it's just special cheese's
you've ever been in there sure have I
always want to go in there sure have Oh
Larson
we're live live come on in man don't be
scared don't be afraid Jake don't be
afraid yeah they'll be afraid that's I
managed shot doing one of the one of the
great comics one of the more unique
comics you got a special drop in soon
we're right into it
if you have a CT we just said no home
before and instead what I say in the
text Thalia was the one I went freaked
out over your especial your last special
oh he did do you know that well he's
always been a big supporter which I mean
Thalia goes to dude dude dude like if if
Thalia goes dude dude dude hold on now
you got you got to see Jay Larson
special it's ridiculous it just came out
that's coming from we're just hitting oh
right off the bat here comes out
tomorrow Friday last one the last one
yeah those a while ago yeah your new one
comes out Friday Friday but it's
available for pre-sale now oh [ __ ] I
mean yeah alright we're excited about it
I can tell you guys are too pretty cries
about it you know I mean yeah Brian
super excited we you get you came in
when we were talking about our white
truffle we had white truffles we had a
meal of white truffles we when it made
me [ __ ] my pants yeah well they're
hardcore man do too much but there are
they they're not even in season right
now educate you I don't think I know
what's up you went to via veneto I get
it you try going to my boy Frank's busy
annals restaurants in New York and every
year he goes to Italy gets the white
truffles comes back and only for a month
can you truffle Master J came in dry
using truffle oil at home haven't you
ever watched a cooking show you never
use that [ __ ] Jay your cuca I like to
cook you guys make my own tomato sauce
bro are you a talent now you you're
Irish or some Larsen Spinelli dude
what's Spinelli to you I thought yeah
goddamn right it is I don't know yeah my
Nana was a Spinelli oh but I'm
everything I'm German I'm are we all
yeah everyone's a mix right yeah a
little-little yeah I'm a diversity of
white people you are a diversity of wipe
we've got a feel being a white comic in
today's world gotta mind your P's and
Q's you gotta find a lot of stuff yeah
gosh where is this oh hey guys we're
live right now I know our aim in life
America's watching you I love it hey go
ahead I want to hear about Via Veneto
actually it's an amazing it make me feel
good it's too much truffles for me we
moved on we put it on our ice cream it
was too much
I mean yet people go bananas about it I
love it what they brought to the table
and let you do yourself well no that's
from Fabrizia so they come in I said oh
my go I want a white truffle for you see
this I'm gonna make the call for you
he's in st. Barths I'm gonna make the
call don't worry about nothing it's
gonna be taken care of
boom we have been oh I assumed that I
was a good sister like that we put white
truffles on ice cream you just did it
this week yeah and how and it was too
much I [ __ ] my pants sir yeah now you
are you Europe you like your food you
like you are you I'm gonna give full
disclosure ok ok and I don't do this
often
I literally and I'm not kidding you just
[ __ ] my pants at a restaurant and I had
to throw my underwear out in the trash
that is a fact
that's just what happened I got a steak
and cheese with mushroom and onion and
some mayo cuz that's a healthy meal yeah
and it's um I thought it was just a toot
or a fart I got kids so it's a toot yeah
and it was it was a little bit more and
it hasn't ever happened to me it's a fun
game to play to and you know right away
you know I was like dude can I get the
key again gonna get the bathroom key and
I'm like everyone's like why this guy's
so aggressive but the bathroom key he's
halfway through that sub dude I get my
keys
and I just I just had to make a run for
it it's so embarrassing you can really
only tell your boys you tell anyone else
like for everybody else's list oh yeah
but you're with your boys understand
that but your pants you ain't doing [ __ ]
great yeah you're not living life to the
fullest but I think that's a great way
to like you know let other people know
that hey if you ever pooped your pants
it's no I we're all in it it's all got
it I've done it as an adult
Morton more than the times I can count
on one hand so yeah usually people give
up after something like that crushed and
yeah yeah shows interest what do you got
like you're gonna fight someone right
after that it's weird a steak sandwich
did that though might be in the bat mail
it might have been the mayo and the
cheese I always am the guy like I don't
know I don't think would happen that
quickly you're apparently apparently
when you eat something they said that
you can have a reaction because the
bacteria builds up over two days
[ __ ] I've ate something in that night
yeah no no that night for sure but they
say also you can have a bad thing and
two days later yeah like the bacterial
count when I get that yeah but that
doesn't work on this story great story
but we're saying that didn't hit you
right away
here's your hitting away I never
believed in like like allergies I just
don't believe in them I know people have
him but I just don't buy it so like we
did their device Brazil not my whole
mouth and swallow up we're going on if
you ate or what if I ate a Brazil nut if
I ate a Brazil nut my mouth will swell
the [ __ ] up okay mom that's [ __ ]
Brazil no I used to eat him so somebody
said you know me here we go when I was
in Iran guys thank you
this guy I want to hear this because
because just very quickly I somebody
said they're good for your liver and
good for endurance so I start putting
him to my shake but I can't figure out
why my throat is super sore and then the
dentist
I got a dentist's he goes did you burn
your mouth I go no the roof of my mouth
swells up and then it burnt like it
would like it looked like it was burning
just Brazilian nuts well my mother will
die from him if she has she has a
quarter one so everything I love
dramatic he can make it sound wait tell
me you don't know no I know I do believe
in them but I never had them and no one
in my family ever had him yeah so like
when I meet people at like my daughter
who's two that we got this test on her
cuz she throws up a lot and like I'll
actually allergic to mushrooms and I'm
like how allergic like is she is she
swelling like no but it's not it's just
not in her like frame we're like all
right whatever yeah and then we gave her
mushrooms down she's fine and she threw
up oh really yeah sure might be allergic
just weak you know you tried the weakest
of the families the weak what he just
needs to step up if she's gonna survive
in the last novel yesterday my buddy's
daughter just got a text about a video
about it she's four years old and she's
in the bedroom
and they're like honey what are you
doing I need privacy I promise it's new
words she learned and my son's two one
knows it whatever God they they open the
door and she cut all her hair off Jesus
comes [ __ ] no long hair she cut her hair
off like s in like ridiculously short
like well how'd she get scissors panic
fired
leave her alone in the room
you're fired yeah she's and they thought
she was playing or something
snip snip snip no hair no hair Junaid oh
yeah literally she had a Britney Spears
meltdown yes app for that might be the
parents she's all smiles her mom's like
thanks the worst yeah like if my kid was
allergic to eggs then the doctor goes
don't worry he'll probably grow out of
it what she did I know like three months
later he's all good so they say about
eggs too
that part of it is they there's a book
called the plant paradox about this they
say that you you can have an allergy to
eggs and in fact it's not the eggs what
you'll have an allergy to is the corn
and soy that the egg the chicken is
being fed and then what they do is I'll
give you pasture-raised eggs so what
does that mean it means that chickens
out there you know yeah he's allergic
literally allergic to the eggs but he
literally eating girl he grew out of it
yeah some allergies I heard you do that
but I heard if you're going eggs the
only way if you really want real the
real deal eggs is pasture-raised like
broken eaters eggs they eat insects I
told you I was embarrassed rose like a
check out when I first came out so yeah
check out the chickens like oh cool I'm
not a rat I grew up in the city I don't
[ __ ] with livestock and you like was
like I'll open the thing else oh god I
was so screaming the chicken yeah man
they look [ __ ] gnarly you're at those
claws man and those become dinosaurs bro
there's a little forest foul the
dinosaurs no you would you I mean grow
up what New York no Massachusetts we
didn't have chickens or anything but if
you never all right though I want to get
one but here's the deal by the way he's
just like a little thing for your
listeners and Watchers I think they say
viewers but if you're gonna buy eggs you
buy the 18 pack that's always people so
let's do buying a dozen I go hey man you
know the 18 is the same price as the 12
right and he goes yeah but what am I
gonna do with 18 eggs and I go you know
what you're gonna do when you're
unpacking your groceries stop boiling
some water pop six in now you get a
snack every day the week at the [ __ ]
help please tell me what you're gonna do
with an egg make a meringue dude
you know that's so [ __ ] weird and
funny make them meringue my dad's
favorite pie lemon meringue pie my
mother used to make really great really
depends on who's making it my mother my
mother would make a lemon meringue pie
for my dad here and there forget it or
chocolate chip cookie dough she'd leave
a little for him we'd be like well I'll
tell you what we need to go public
she likes she'd apply he likes a good
idea likes all the dough well yeah who
cook everyone duh yeah he's um that's
American all right oh no I like an ice
pecan pie myself oh that's tough on the
teeth do you know Steve I don't like
your teeth no Vic yeah I mean they're
rich Thanksgiving a nice pecan gasps
what are you doing with that the next
day in the morning bro yep a coffee cold
pie [ __ ] it guys that's not good for
your body that's what I'm talking right
now man I've been really trying to cut
back on the fats and [ __ ] you know I
mean that's why when I had that steak
and cheese that I was like at least I'm
doing something healthy and then it just
goes right through they say fats aren't
to worry it's the sugar
yeah well the coke I had to wash it down
it's caught up that'll do it you know
what I mean I don't buy it I don't
believe it but have you ever been on
like the strict diet yeah yeah I drop
ten pounds in one month just doing no
sugar no carbs no dairy no caffeine
how'd you feel that sounds like no fun I
was I felt great you know what I mean I
was energetic people like man you look
so good and I was like yeah you know you
look like a younger Bryan Callen and I
was like oh wow food is really emotional
and weird food is like one of those
things where like it seems like diets
for most people never ultimately stick
and you always go back to your set point
it's really hard I don't know it's a
it's a weird very hard I was talking
about this with Jo yesterday I looked at
it as I was eating this bowl of is a
healthy chili yeah but I was I want the
unhealthy chili yeah I looked I said I
think any see a therapist about eating
well you why because you have hang-ups
about it or die just want to eat
everything yeah you can eat but you also
work out like a [ __ ] and you
ultimately are pretty disciplined about
it but you do you are always doing this
you are always doing serration I'm
always doing something always either
keto or he's this or he's that he's okay
gotta get on that tip do you though I
feel like you're pretty happy I'm happy
most of them I go on diets aren't like
go of life is great you know they're a
little weird people are too involved in
the diet it's my thumb my my uncle say
you ever see a happy jogger
it's just jogging cuz I gotta work out
just kidding and the guys I find me a
jogger who smile I love jogging but with
the diet like anyone whose balls deep
and I'm counting their calories and
macros [ __ ] you
that's not littering I've never heard
anyone say that someone was balls deep
and dieting oh yeah oh yeah yeah I just
need to make a lifestyle change and be
like I got a workout I can't walk up a
flight of stairs and be exhausted with
two kids you know I mean I got to step
up my game
but do you work out no yeah but I got it
all [ __ ] work out on him I've never
fought anyone else like this we're
enjoying the conversation just a boy
just to break a sweat just to [ __ ]
yeah just to get in shape I know I got
to man I'm gonna start I'm gonna start
do you though are you happy I'm pretty
happy but I use food is like food for me
is I need it that it's it's a soothing
thing yeah me too if I'm feeling great
I'm like let's get some [ __ ] nice to
eat and if I'm feeling like [ __ ] I'm
like I need to [ __ ] shake and a
Ferger
I go to in-n-out I'm the guy who's like
you let me get that double-double with
the coke and let me get it let me get a
shake as well or do you not want the
coke I'm like [ __ ] shut up
okay I want to bowl [ __ ] I'll wash it
down and I need the swing-u I really
think a lot of it has to do with whether
or not that gives you comfort yeah the
OP when I eat that it makes me feel like
[ __ ] so I tend to I think I associate it
with not feeling good it just depends
what you associate and I got to switch
it up I don't know if you do I don't I
don't know well I think he makes fun of
me because I box where I work out I
don't make funny because you box work
out I make funny could you tell me about
no no no but what I'm saying is I told
you you'd be annoyed how much I know but
I think I work out I mean I think all
the source of my exercise whether it's
Bogner is yes I like learning new things
but it's also deep-seated insecurities
yes that's what you were seeing it like
you know like dissatisfaction with my
resting point I think you always wanted
to be you know it's not things pretty
much I mean I think we're all weird we
offer
Jim was like whoa what you're like no no
doubt he's known me for three months
yeah yeah yeah yeah but that's not at
least you're working out you know yeah
I'd be better than if you you know if
you had a deep insecurity you're doing
like coke and hookers yeah I honestly
just think that weight is the one thing
that's holding me back in all aspects of
my life and if I overcome that it'll
clear up everything else really yeah I
really do or no or you get skinny and
you're not funny more like I thought
about when I started going skinny you
were funny when you remember oh you were
all can't wait because you were like hey
bro sorry I mean I mean everyone says it
like that you're the better half of the
deal but even the sensitivity level oh
my god I just met the guy I just mean
you're you were thinner before that's
yes much much much but whatever I mean
is that what we got two kids a beard was
before you know what it was it was
quitting smoking and then getting into a
long-term relationship so you got
comfortable in the long-term
relationship we go [ __ ] and I'm on the
prowl anymore but also smoking you just
replaced that little food with food and
also smoking increases your metabolism
it does panic it puts down your Preston
cigarettes you're like [ __ ] I'm like
what am I gonna eat I'm gonna smoke a
lot and it relieves stress you forget
like that little cigarette just relieves
stress if you're doing that 20 times a
day be cool if they could come up with a
cigarette those wasn't so bad for you so
you could still do aren't those vape
pens like they're not great fries that I
made with alcohol I use it at night not
good there are there what there makes
whether or not they're better for you
they think than cigarettes what about
what about for we'd like same thing
again I thought yeah smoking putting
smoke in your body it's not healthy
right but it's better than you never
smoked no cigarette again I have a
constitution you know that's why I
really when people say well I have
nothing do with discipline it's just I I
don't do well with like I'm delicate
like if I drink whiskey I guess I'm like
the next day forget it I'm gonna [ __ ]
up if I smoke weed I'm pretty much high
for the next week but if you're drinking
wine how do you even air though how
about different I came to drink wine at
night
it [ __ ] me up I gotta feel well cause I
had one glass of wine he's nice because
you're 50 because when you're young you
just drink a lot more wine when you get
older you get more sensitive yeah I hear
that's right five white travel to ship
my pin yeah yeah when I was younger I
couldn't do it yeah I could do that be
fine right when you're when you're 50
you definitely feel a [ __ ] difference
how old are you just 41 yeah but I felt
it 30 and then I felt it at 40 now I'm
like hey I better get ahead of it now I
just think it'll be more fun I like to
eat and I like to drink but I if I
worked out more I could totally
alleviate that but what about if you see
what about is there something physical
you could do where weight was getting in
the way so it's like for me like I
genuinely enjoy playing tennis and
boxing I just like it like it's fun to
go mm-hmm so then I go all right I'm
gonna do some deadlift cuz it'll make me
stronger and I'll eat a certain way so
I'm so I feel energized so it's almost
like what I'm - all of it is I'm doing
it cuz it's the fun of the game yeah I
think you need that I think you have to
do it it's gotta be I know I can't be
like discipline what about what is your
family healthy - like is your wife
healthy we're both you know we go up and
down but she's healthier than I am cuz
you can just get a salad I mean cool
genetics right let's grab a quick app I
know an app dessert on the palate even
though when I eat when I'm like oh this
is good but you know what I mean you
want I can talk myself into literally
anything anything those boots are three
great hard well go on a show next
weekend
[ __ ] he's amazing what's wrong what's
wrong with two scoops ice cream you're
not gonna work out tomorrow there's a
sketch of that money it'll be a Tuesday
and he's like I don't know you see the
pie no I think it's the pie I go yeah
it's Tuesday no what I mean is I mean
you know we worked hard all right okay I
feel like we deserve it yeah I'm the
opposite man I'll be sitting there
looking at the menu and I'm like it'll
be like don't order the steak and cheese
don't own us steak and cheese doughnuts
they can use what would you like let me
get the steak and cheese Marsha I just
know the whole time wonder what that is
my thing is is my girl my house she was
crazy genetics she can eat whatever the
[ __ ] she wants every night of the week
and she's good she doesn't but it's just
different yeah so so they did a there's
actually a scientist
reason for that for wanting all of it
right away
for fats for wanting fats and sweets
because evam an evolutionary point of
view when you were in the tundra
when you were like our ancestors when
there was a fig tree that was
essentially in bloom you've got to stock
up you eat all those figs because
monkeys are gonna get to it and it's the
last time you're gonna come across those
figs interesting so we learned how to
stockpile nutrients and fat and protein
when we could get it oh well maybe or
when I was a kid my pinch like Sheree
can of ice cream and everyone I'm Kim
addicted to sugar at a young age but we
still have a genetic propensity for that
we've evolved our brains have evolved
for that our brains evolved to get it
take it when you can get it and that
means gorging yeah you know so it's Ritz
it did so a lot of it can be that too
either way you should be able to get
ahead of science I just write a book
about it yeah III get that at the same
time like there I could have sweets in
the every minute of the day if I want
the resources are there there's a lot of
people who don't you can I can't yeah I
haven't shown a lot of people can
nobody's saying you can get it yeah all
right well no but I think I also might
like my daughter like I give it's
awfully a lot of science with the
ancestor stuff how oh we're genetically
you know eat the Paleo diet well we've
changed we've adapted that doesn't work
for today's society by the way some
people to my daughter can eat half a
cookie and be like OOP and save it for
that my son like you know you put six
cookies out there my son's gonna eat off
for months a lot of [ __ ] half oh come
on that way too I have a show yeah I'm
like I'm full I can't tell now how for
kooky not me dude if you leave half a
cookie I'll be pissed
crush fest if it's around it's getting
hammered but I won't say this back to
the fake thing my neighbors have a fig
tree and they were like hey we got all
these figs you want them and I'm like
yeah I made a fig jam pass it out the
neighborhood whatever oh I like that fig
jam every time my son goes to school
needs his peanut butter and fig sandwich
who made that [ __ ] this guy I love of
nice fig jam
I don't like figs regular but a nice
fish do you make a lot of sugar it's a
lot of sugar
yeah it'd you just you cut them up with
waters you throw them in boiling water
with sugar and you let him simmer until
it's a fig jam Wow that's it and it's
delicious it's fantastic you [ __ ] him
with that almond butter he's the peanut
butter with the
still yeah we do peanut butter.you
peanut yeah we don't have any allergies
why you just go straight up all my like
an almond powder myself yeah a nice
almond butter he's even cashew butter
these days I don't really mess with
peanut butter cashew butter peanut
butter nightshade vegetables they say
well I remember like going to like camp
and like when they didn't have they'd
have almond butter everyone's like huh
man you were the nerdiest crazy all the
[ __ ] up in here Derek's papers [ __ ]
camp almond butter
especially organic almond butter that
[ __ ] raw elements yeah I mean yeah
there's like flex on peanut butter
though peanut butters fading away a
little bit man it's not as good for you
as the almond butter almond butter don't
have the same sugar you know yeah it's
just healthier in general for it and
it's delicious my son's almond milk now
[ __ ] cows nectar there's almond milk
now bro house nectar we crush all no
good for you at the end of the day sure
is it it sure is a kids go through a
milk we're the only species that drinks
other animals milk yeah but that's bogus
too because most most cultures like like
a lot of northern European cultures
lived on milk you know Europe and stuff
I'm not saying I just wonder if it's
yeah but not not they live on nut but
not sort of past infancy when you're a
kid you need after that you don't need
it yeah and it has to be whole milk but
if you're in kids skip skim milk makes
zero [ __ ] sense the way it solved all
terrain it now no it's all sugar and
what it's sugar water it's sugar water
that's white right there's nothing in
that stuff we used to just grab me and
my brother would like grab the gallon
milk turmeric and just shut down it a
gallon of milk a day and easy like that
was like Jesus Christ same thing we're
just down it because we thought does the
way to get big and strong yeah well in a
way yeah it sounds cool yeah I mean you
do get your fats and proteins if it's
whole don't that there's not much going
on to digest right it's just not it's
not good for doctors still tell you they
tell you you have to give your baby
whole milk they're like you got a tease
yes we said what we wanted to give
almond milk we like to back off and he
was like well then you're gonna have to
give a supplement to get all the
vitamins and fats and all that really
has to be one just go with yeah my kid
lives and dies off the whole milk yeah
it's good for the syringe but as a grown
man you drinking milk I can't do it well
I mean if you're a grown adult sipping
on milk yeah you're an ass I killed
cheese I'll kill a [ __ ] good Ross
different bro right she's for Jessica's
you know what she's also the lactose
breaks down I guess when you when you
make cheese and an F it's a goat or a
sheep I can eat it for [ __ ] days I
like a nice calm tea why Tom tea is good
I'm too pumped in kanji bumped Co m PT
what's that look like it you've had it
before you had a nice you know it's got
the calcium in it so you've got that
little crunch in it a little high like a
nice crunch in mind yeah well this I
mean come on
Parmesan there's certain I mean there's
certain cheese's what do we like the old
not aged overlearn look [ __ ] yeah that
that was the stuff I had it was a raw
aged provolone from Europe and it was a
dry sharp provolone for [ __ ] I like only
like sharp cheese's - goddamn right if
it's a mild cheddar [ __ ] yeah chatter
Wisconsin the aged for ten years hooks
chatter you gonna pay you need that
sweet English cheddar man well the
Shropshire no that's where cheddar can
you say that word one more time
sharp shower no traps are trap Shire I
want to make my own cheese see that when
I may just run through some ideas that I
feel like we should start a cheese so
making your own cheese about three of us
I know but I've seen some processes you
go ahead and get ourselves a cave yep
well you could eat land first you need
to rent it you know what rennet is we
need some towels do you know you know
what rennet is fur for ten points how
they used to trace them and they still
make cheese in some places so rennet it
way haunt it they let it they let it age
right let it's my age I mean but the
[ __ ] what about go ahead okay so they
can so next point the wine I won those
ten point they would do is they take the
milk and they will get it curdle well
they'd let it curl but they what are
they put in it right what is rennet it's
really fascinating
I mean vinegar rennet is actually the
intestine the what's in the intestine of
a calf before it actually eats grass
it's it's it's when the calf has only
drunk its mother's milk you would take
that as a bum-out and put it in the
cheese that's not my choice not if we
start a cheese business I'm not doing
that
I use vegetable rennet now I have done
different things who who was like you
know what I'm thinking I know they can
cutting out this part of the cow I don't
write that baby cow put it might have
been a mistake you know a lot of things
these happen who knows when she cheese
was she's been around from before the
Romans I mean you know yeah
pecorino they used to eat a salty cheese
you know that's all you know get out of
my face yeah I'm making a nice baked
baked eggplant parm tonight for the
family and I do and I like nice Oppel oh
yeah you how do you do it
I just saute the eggplant sure in olive
oil do a layer that layer a sauce layer
cheese what kind of sauce some kind of
cheese I just use Rao's jarred you know
I mean I'm not with my own you like
Rao's no but I could tell by the way he
scratched his mustache that he got
disappointed cuz I thought you made your
own socket I do well by the way you went
well you ain't the same guy he said you
make your own sauce cuz my dad but um my
dad he's he's balls-deep in Italy
whatever he's like I'm this Italian chef
night comes the house they're gonna make
you pasta so I'm hoping a can don't pay
I'm like what well no that's not your
past is it that's what is that ragout
that's ragu pasta you're not making your
own pasta yeah see I'm Italian for real
yeah my mother would I mean the idea
that we get something out of a can why
like like we're not late if I'm around
your mom sure if I vomit on your mom I
see ragu she goes no oh my god why the
weight she makes her own sauce all the
time hun percent Sicilians call gravy
well her mother's from not born on
murdered there her father's from Chaka
from Santa cosa in honey okay sorry are
you gonna pull out a sword in two
seconds the way you lookin at me
I love that man I love that my Nana used
to make her own gravy
she wouldn't always I was saying this
you know they like when we you know was
just my mom in the house so when my Nana
would be there every day we get home
from school and we'd be like can we eat
were starving and every time there was
pasta she'd have the gravy going and she
begged get over here and she take a
piece of bread and just dunk it in the
sauce it's nice and then put it on a
plate with a fork
yeah how good was that Oh insane we
would get in there with the bread forget
it so wait do you have a recipe then for
your sauce yeah you don't cause it's
expected that it's a beast to cook your
own sauce no I don't
I don't have it I'm a my sauce when I'm
all my pieces but if I'm like euro pizza
yeah I can't do it all the time like you
have to just like when Rao's is on sale
at Whole Foods for 399 I'm gonna buy
three yeah I know there's a trivia
question for you [ __ ] do you know what
food is responsible for the expansion of
British power in the seventeen hundreds
1800s what I would what food is
responsible for essentially the British
Empire I mean it's kind of a [ __ ]
Italian if there's one food it's weird
think about it think about why in
England think about why it'd be one food
that's responsible is it a food or is it
a dress of food it's a food okay that
you eat or its ingredient you would eat
it have we talked about it today good
question but but it's a very good
question but it's something you'd eat
cuz rumor back then you had to eat the
whole thing right so it's kind of
[ __ ] fascinating is it bread I'm say
rice potatoes it's not rice potatoes
week so so so okay here so loot so
sailors used to live on beef jerky and
biscuits okay what was the problem with
that couldn't breath scurvy
what is scurvy from do you hate that he
knows so much I mean it's got to get
annoying you know but it's actually
fascinating because sosa scurvy is when
you don't have enough vitamin C we
didn't know that mm-hmm so up to two
million sailors literally like when you
went on an expedition it was a given
that literally probably three-quarters
or even all of your sailors would die if
it was a long trip cuz they just weren't
eating fruits vegetables so your teeth
would fall out you'd lose control your
limbs and you would just die of scurvy
and they couldn't figure out what the
[ __ ] it was until this doctor basically
said you know vitamin C citrus has
always been a folk remedy for for scurvy
let's try it so he had them bring lemons
and stuff because lemons actually rot
this guy
Captain Cook you know from Peter Pan of
course James Cook he [ __ ] took
sauerkraut now what why sauerkraut it's
cabbage basically in salt power food
yeah so he made his officers and the
molecular sacrum
they wouldn't sauerkraut and then he
made them whenever they port eat all the
fresh fruits and vegetables they could
they didn't really understand why but if
he they knew it was something in it so
none of them
now when he came back not one of that it
had scurvy which was unprecedent but
what that meant was the other countries
like Spain and the other countries
didn't know this secret so the British
kept it a secret along and they were
like they so they'd be fighting a bunch
of [ __ ] scurvy infested soldiers and
passengers and they were like you guys
you can't fight when you when your teeth
are falling out and you can't use your
arms so they basically ran the seat I
almost well because of sauerkraut I
almost went with fish and chips you've
had a nice fish and chips out there you
know you like fish and chips sauce what
if you eat raw fish at all like raw deer
there's a lot of vitamins and believe it
or not so the Native Americans even
though they ate a lot of other stuff you
keep going yeah no I like I mean I love
that you have this vast knowledge yeah
so do you make your own sauce I mean I
just want to get back to it well he
threw his mom in my face in his
grandmother and then our little scurvy
tale let's write a TED talk it's right
ahead talk no you know what dude I um I
don't mind my wife my wife cooks I'm so
masculine do that box yeah so for me
what do you do for sauce in the house
your wife sauce you know I bet he counts
at meal times I'll tell you right now
they're [ __ ] buying out the bottle
Hey yeah excuse me your wife ain't
making no homey sauce that never
happened she actually does have to be
fair to her she actually does she'll be
mad if she hears this and I don't give
her credit she does make her own sauce
my mother though if I were to call my
mother and say how to give me the recipe
it'd be it'd be game over okay that's
besan it's rare though you find someone
making sauces these yeah because you can
buy good bottled sauces you sure can't
my sauce is slamming that when I make it
from scratch I can't do that a minute
yeah and it's expensive I had a little
bit of an advantage too this is
something you don't know about me
ask LaFonte tomato sauce and one of you
know my grandfather's clef on e that was
his tomato company the sauce company and
he was one of the first people to get to
goodbye he made tomatoes from the way
the old country did he said go [ __ ]
yourself
acetylene chambers and your synthetic
fertilizer my tomatoes are grown in [ __ ]
they grown in manure and they're ripen
on the vine and that's how and I went to
his factory and he
truckloads of vine ripened Tomatoes and
that's how they would make a funny
tomato sauce I'll tell you what is ill
around yeah
the factory still there yeah we're in
New Jersey so it's the best it's hi did
he pass away yeah but my don't give you
anything chol to get over do we only we
all the fact we don't my uncle took it
over and he then sold it I think to his
cousin son-of-a-bitch let's go finding
tomato sauce it's good tomato though you
can eat it like an apple man oh of
course
yeah cherry yeah that's what Europe's
good for Italy like when you get it when
they cut a tomato red throw and throw oh
it's got to be read through and through
now tell me if this is ever happened so
I was home I don't know this is like six
months ago and my boy Ryan Sickler was
with me and I'm like my mom was like I'm
gonna make it dinner come over and my
family's gonna be there
this is impossible yeah just outside and
stone them and my mom's taking us
through the kitchen and she's showing us
everything that she's gonna make and
she's been talking about her homemade
sauce and all this stuff and she's like
tells right like I made the meatballs or
scratch and the eggplant parm is not my
recipe which meant it was out of a box
frozen and then she was and I made the
sauce and I go well hold up I go you
made that sauce she was yeah I gotta
know you didn't she was yes I did and
then I have a salad and she pointed all
these other things right and then she
goes alright Ryan let me show you the
rest of the house and I go whoa back up
I go before we go any further I need you
to admit you didn't make this sauce and
she goes yes I did chase and I go mod no
I'm you've never made a sauce I go I
didn't I don't believe you made this she
was yes I did I heard you made this
sauce you J I go
you're lying MA you're lying to Ryan and
she goes comer up she was you know what
I ran out of homemade and I had put a
jar in with it okay Jason and that's the
light too it was alright of a joke
that's a delicious a lie it was great
but here's the deal my brother had
warned me goes y'all be heads up on Ma's
meatballs and I go why he goes cuz
they're always like undercooked in the
middle so we're that's disgusting I'm
helpful my mother put dinner out right
and the last thing is the meatballs and
I grabbed from a hand I got whoa hold up
she's a waggle gotta check these
meatballs she goes what are you talking
about and I take one meatballs and I cut
her open I go ma it's wrong in the
middle she goes so and I go are you
[ __ ] crazy just don't swear at me
like she like distract me from these raw
meatballs I go you can't serve raw
meatballs and she goes what do you
want me to do J and I go right cook them
and I wish I went in the dining room I
gotta put the meatballs down and then I
had to walk around to my seat like
through other rooms and I get to my seat
now rise the only one whose touch the
meatballs he's got one let's play I go
yo just a heads up those meatballs are
raw in the middle no one ate a meatball
and then later my mother called me on it
she's I can't believe you told people
those were ramen well they were
delicious I go mom you can't serve a raw
meatball she owes have you ever had a
medium-rare hamburger and I was like
that logic I want it to work but I'm
like nah meatballs too small I agree
with you man it's funny I'd have to have
hilarious you can't feed the [ __ ]
people wrong no she does not and she's
known for it that's her thing that's her
thing she doesn't know cooking temps and
stuff she was a single mom she didn't
cook that much you got your single mom
single mom a four of them single mom at
27 your dad just dipped out yeah bounced
that's fine no wonder you're a comic
yeah and like so my mom like my Nana
will cook or migrate out McCook my mom
was never too busy dad sounds like a
great guy took off with four kids sweet
dude sweet guy yeah I did he passed away
a couple years ago but like we saw him
like on and off until I was like 10 and
then I saw him once when I was 36 like
we set up a time to go meet and my wife
came and stuff how was that it was
crazier animosity towards him but when
you're 36 yeah when you're 30 you know
those shows like when they're older like
you know I've let all the anger ago I'm
just gonna I'm gonna have it I can't
appreciation with them code I would
never be like that I mean I did I just
finally realized I'm like this dude's
never gonna apologize it's not it is he
doesn't think that's something but we
start emailing when I was like 22 and
like that's when I reconnected and then
like we dip out and then two years later
I hit him up again and you know stuff
like that what did he do he's an antique
dealer how weird yeah he was like always
reading books on silver and coins and
like was super knowledgeable but he my
grandfather owned a bakery and so my dad
worked at the bakery when I was a kid
and then my dad kind of run in the
ground and my grandfather sold it and
like dad just went in antiques you know
and but what but why did he do pout on
the four kids we don't know man like if
he never gave you an excuse like now
he told me like your mother was so hard
to deal with bubble butt but you at the
same time you like yeah well I got two
kids I would even if I hated my wife I
would still be like that's my those are
my clear correct
so who knows man some people just don't
have it like I don't understand it it's
the one thing I find unforgivable yeah I
can't pardon it yeah like I I just can't
did the rest of your families give him a
pass - no no one no one I was on I was
the last one to like have any content
else that [ __ ] yeah everyone like we
had a letter until the youngest you were
the youngest yeah everyone else had told
him like [ __ ] peace bro
hell yeah but it's crazy so he checked
this out it was like this story in my
family but one time my dad like my
sister wouldn't finish her orange juice
so my dad poured the pitcher over her
head
and it was just like I kept this yeah
this this this diamond and I was like on
a shoot and like we were having like a
family meal with like the whole crew and
one of the producers telling me that
exact story happened in their house and
it's a big joke like they make fun of
their dad for and he's ashamed that I'm
like it's all in how you look at things
and so like one my wife was out of town
and I had the two kids she was out of
town a lot so I'm with him a lot and I'm
sure my son had like had three meltdowns
in a row and we I got them both in the
bath and I got all right I'm gonna go
take River and I'm gonna get her like
dry it off you stay in the bath and he
has a meltdown and I'm like frustrating
I grabbed his face and I go what do you
want me to do yeah right and later he
comes up to me he goes are you happy dad
and I go get over here I go yeah I'm
happy you make me happy I go something
you gotta know about that dad runs a
little hot from time to time dad was
right here dude and I just was like I
realized at that moment I'm like he just
needs to know who I am it's not like I
need to
yes I'm obviously not gonna always snap
but like if you explain hey people are
the way people are sometimes people are
flawed he came home with a book from
school and they had little different
flowers in each flower represented a
different emotion and he goes that's you
daddy and it was the red one for anger
Wow
and I was just like yeah yeah sometimes
sometimes he swear to God is doing your
sister freaking out how old are they
he's three and a half and she's too
young yes but I mean I grabbed his
[ __ ] face but you know I mean I feel
like it's like this thing like I I have
a big thing right now that I'm working
on I'm like why we constantly trying to
change the
things and people are and just start
trying to accept them for what they are
instead of like oh you need to be more
of course you should work at being
calmer but at the same time like hey how
about we just laugh it when Dad gets
upset right and make it a joke as a
house you know well Brian I talked about
this we have a friend and I've done
better at this because sometimes I'd
hold resentment towards people where I
expected them to want the same thing I
wanted for them like man I should expect
the tow to get this role I expect to be
this type of comic or expect to be this
successful and do you need to work like
that and then when they weren't I get so
upset and then finally one does like
maybe he just doesn't give a [ __ ] yeah
dude maybe I care more than he does
that's so funny I know man I'm good I'm
like I don't care I don't check in I'm
like whatever you wants do ya I love him
great dude I snapped on my friend the
other day for the same exact thing he
was asking me for advice and I go I
start telling them all I go you realize
that gave you all this advice five years
ago and you haven't done one thing and
yet you're completely content and and my
wife was like hey maybe that's not what
he wants Jay maybe he doesn't want what
you want and I was like yeah maybe my
father it's like a switch yep for me it
was a switch cuz I'd get so upset at a
bunch of people like why the [ __ ] cuz
you're more discipline and all of a
sudden it's just like juvenile
oh I don't give a [ __ ] anymore yeah
because they don't want it why do I do
you you don't represent my buddy was
though as I had my father I go he's got
pipe dreams
it's just pipe dreams I'm trying to help
him make his dreams come reality my
father goes hey he likes his pipe dreams
he's a pipe dream she doesn't want his
dreams to be anything but pipe dreams
leave him alone yeah the same thing I
went and it took took all the pressure
off me well for me I was walked around
angry for like months and months at
certain people I'd be upset if they
weren't disciplined this year this year
and it'd be exhausting for me and I'd
vent to my girl or vent to my other
friends and literally switches like whom
who gives a [ __ ] man they don't want
that yeah that's all good now yeah so
basically you're [ __ ] anyone you just
realize you can't do anything and you're
not gonna be able to help them with that
and there's a part of it that's like
you're projecting on them what you want
for yourself so you figure if you
motivate them to do it it's gonna like
come back and Traverse Lee if that's the
right word
do it for you as well and you can't you
just have to be like if they asked for
it give it if they don't like why are
you looking super investing and then
they just then then the worst thing is
then they just take it from you and
don't use it and then you feel like
trash cuz just energy and then it's not
being used but it's on you because it's
yeah they didn't ask for it
I've got out that and I've also cut out
people who I own I only hear from them
when they want something I don't talk to
me oh yeah I just don't respond anyone I
cut out that and dairy so I've been
cutting out see smart no but I know what
you mean I did the same thing I'm just
like like don't only hit me up if they
need to need something the only time
hear from is they only need some and I
was like I'm done man
I'm done oh I see what you're doing
that's what this is on Mount man yeah I
don't know we always talk about this but
like I feel like the most interesting
people hold me hold my hand the most
interesting we had a break are your
hands are heavy carry heavy hands
yeah sweet catch it yeah thank you the
like I like we have kids all of us and
we do everything we can to make their
lives comfortable and they loved and
cloister and all that and then the most
interesting people I know at least the
best comics and just the most successful
people all came from some childhood
trauma likes Casey came from some
parental dysfunction yeah well I think
right yeah of course that's the irony I
don't know well I think the key is for
me at least what I'm trying to do and
I'd say to my wife I'm like hey they're
gonna have me and they're gonna have
more money than I had but at the same
time I'm gonna plant that damn chip that
I had yeah on their shoulder and let it
plan it way you can give them Drive and
you can make up or you can show them do
you can't show them work I think I don't
think implant a chip you can show um by
example yeah I can give him stuff true
well I try left a baby and I'm like
straight up all the time like the first
day my kid went to school my son he was
two and a half or like yeah I'm sorry
preschool yeah I'm like you carry your
lunch and dude I don't carry your lunch
and I don't carry you
I see people carrying the kids I'm like
not my kid you carry your own yeah and
that's the littlest tiniest sure but I'm
like it gets him to that like hey this
is my lunches and my responsibilities
you know it's a little things but it's
like you know I think he's gonna grow up
different no matter what though yes of
course what of course not unless I
bounce which every now and then I'd mix
it up me
mix it up and just outside no peace see
you later I worked out for me this is
for your buddy it's just for you have
you got a new girl in film leaving with
a Bible and a video if you tell them how
to Sean I'm out of shape and then the
family recipe for sauce it's so funny
you say that I didn't learn how to shave
till I was a freshman in college I've
thought about making videos for my kids
and get especially my son in case I die
totally I know same here on the things I
wonder does a man yes 100% details
mm-hmm you should yeah and your daughter
yeah because if you are received let me
just have you ever seen that documentary
on the football player it was the NFL
football player and got the horrible
cancer the disease and his son just was
born and his brain is his verbal
communication skills are gonna shut down
he was like three years
so he's making videos from all his
knowledge where his son Wow no he
actually has someone you said that it
you know but this guy really had to get
all this knowledge out in time I'm free
it's a st. Louis I'm sorry it's the New
Orleans Saints
safety they have a statue of him he's
looking up chin he was that he stands
the guy who who he blocked the field
goal when remember after Hurricane
Katrina he blocked the funeral Beeson
and there's the documentary I guarantee
you you will cry when you watch it I'm
sure because he no no he is the he is
the foundation where he's like trying to
raise awareness for ALS he has her I
think so something like that but they
he's doing the video for his son right
before he's born Steve Gleason Steve
Gleason Wow
watch the Gleason documentary will knock
your [ __ ] well I mean I don't know if
this affected you but when Ralphie
passed that was something that like
crush me I think we saw Ralphie was
gonna pass like it wasn't a shock yeah
but then you're like holy [ __ ] I'm four
years younger than him I have two kids
if I left at 45 they'd be six and five
and they're locked man those kids I
really [ __ ] over of course well you
don't have you have a bunch of the offer
you know I'm saying like I don't know
you really I just [ __ ] met you but
yeah seemed like a good stand-up guy
like you there's some knowledge can drop
on those kids man hunch good dude that's
what like me my brother used to joke
around about like the fact that my dad
wasn't around cuz my grandfather lived
on the ocean and my dad had a boat and
[ __ ] and I was like don't
you realize we should have been sailors
we should be ceiling I should have
lobster traps at ten like I'm like sold
lobsters em around and like should've
been building stuff yeah none of that
learned none of it I everything that I
know is like what I learned on my own
dad had a boat never took you on it no I
mean I don't know if he had it it was
around when he was in like high school
he had a boat and had lobster traps and
then we're going to town and sell the
lobsters to restaurants and stuff you
know I mean and like my grandfather had
a boat so look you got a bunch of
knowledge like ALS yeah
it's a crazy thing that's the trailer
there and you could play that trailer
chin alright man well they won't be able
to see the video right now but also the
to build a hair dryer in here is gonna
be shitty oh it's [ __ ] as part I know
so should we not do it alright yeah it's
gonna keep pausing and I'm probably
gonna start crying right now oh oh
waterworks I was like uh-huh
anything that stud to do I can yeah
we'll watch this plus it's gonna come in
and out you know telling you if that
thing well I'm sure game changer any of
that stuff that has to like spill but
he's this you know NFL captain of the
switch teams
they sure yeah I mean Jack think his
disease and we find that he has he's
like what the [ __ ] and then you know as
a big strong powerful dude that those
things start to go and his wife becomes
pregnant he's like man I gotta drop
knowledge on the ski cuz I'm not gonna
be able to talk so he just has the baby
he's like a son he's just trying to all
this data all this data man yeah that's
a lot that's a lot because you want to
be able to be there for all those things
like I made this list one time for like
the 10 things like 10 things I spoke
with this dad conference I want to do
with my kid before they you know that's
good when they grow up
there was like you know different stuff
like I want to have a beer with my kid
before he's 21 like yeah I picture my
son like having a like a horrible day
like it's something to me like let's go
to Playa del Rey and like go to the
dunes and bring two beers and sit there
and then hop on the [ __ ] water did I
mean like I want to give him money for a
date same with my daughter like here you
take this money in case this guy or
chick whatever it is doesn't have any
number ten was live above my son's
garage after his mom dies there's a good
chance that's happening like I plant
like you know you have friends who's
like move to LA and then like their
parents move to be near them yes that's
gonna be me I'm like you know call your
kids I hope you like you cool if I just
come on let me live above the rock for
you that's every night I come home
American dinner yeah be great man that'd
be great with nothing else to do I have
to do you look forward to retirement
yeah you do I would never retire I have
a lot of interest in things that I want
to do like even like jobs that I want to
try and do what about like what do you
mean jobs well like there's different
things I would love to do like what like
I love you Entertainment know some in
but somehow you know what an
entertainment do you want to do they
that you haven't done I mean produce on
a real level you know any mean like make
real stuff where you take other people's
visions and like help get them out there
you know what about you guys I'd like to
direct as well I mean there's a lot of
things I like you know right now I'm
just like in what I'm in you know did
and you said for me retirement be I
don't even I am in the middle of the
biggest grind ever been the entirety
just I mean yeah you've done a bunch of
stuff though you mean you've lived like
three careers he's a man yeah yeah he's
a grinder well you got it let me know
this business is a grind how long you
been doing it like five years 25 years
and still people look at what you do and
they're like is it great is it like just
decent work you know what I mean yeah
you know for me like stand-up is my
great Savior like just makes you feel
like you're [ __ ] oh I didn't get the
joke [ __ ] how [ __ ] up that Sam yeah
you're right I was like meter that I
mean that's what everyone I never feel
like I've but what counts might nom
come at me yeah well I mean you could
have you could be content you know I
mean you could be like oh this is no cuz
today everything I've ever done in fact
I don't even want to look at the other
stuff yeah I think my last special was
really good frankly that's the only
thing I can watch but I think my next
thing is gonna be Who I am
yeah you know so so as long as I'm
working in that like I'm on my way to
Calgary right now right tonight and and
I'll be there Thursday Friday this
Thursday Friday Saturday by the way
y'all cooks everybody but I'm excited
because it's new you're trying to work
it out and I'm still unfolding layers
and I'm and I just love that and I can
think about it all day but I also think
your last special if the learning thing
for you to cuz you didn't do it right
yeah and then now you can do it right
right why didn't you do it right last
time I just have my friend shoot it and
just the wrong way the whole marketing
all the there's too much he's the
[ __ ] man when it comes to market too
much no really yeah he knows was you're
supposed to come out it comes out Friday
available where if we were at my website
Oh DJ Larson comedy calm all right I
paid for it I produced it I made the
whole thing that's smart investing in
yourself yeah did you even get Netflix
to watch it Netflix did watch it and and
they passed why I don't know
I fired my manager shortly after we got
passes I was like what did you guys do
like how did this even happen and I was
like then I got a couple offers that
were just so bad I was like such
disrespect I'm like you guys so crazy
though that's what's crazy yeah it's a
real do it it's a I'm really proud of it
it's er I think it's a really solid hour
and everyone that's seen it no you're
undeniable like people have been like
dude how is this not sold and I'm like I
was gonna hold it and just like wait cuz
like I was gonna wait for new managers
and I was like you know what now I'm
gonna put it out I'm gonna put it out I
put my money into it if I can't buy and
if I came buying to myself why can't I
expect anybody else to invest in it and
forget it and then you know what I did I
got hardcore and I have two albums
before this one I went to the label on
my bottom back I'm like I want to own
all my stuff I don't want anyone owning
my material this is my life you know
what I mean because the hiring the last
ten minutes of my special is a story
about when my dad did die two and a half
years ago I went home and went through
his house and all this stuff his wife
let me go through everything and so I
told that the last ten minutes
and
I had like pitched that idea to like
commie central or HBO or Netflix they be
like Matt's a little heavy well I was
like yeah you know what I really want to
get that story stories funny you know
there's money moments at car just give
us a teaser of the funny that you saw
with your dad's life well I mean like I
was like looking through his house for
like signs of me you know I mean which
is kind of first of all the fact that I
just show up at his wife's door like hey
she was cool with it
yeah can I go through his stuff real
quick and like I found out he was
bisexual this was odd what did you find
out my aunt told me well they were like
sculptures everywhere of penises and and
I and I remember since I've been super
in like my he left he had a lifelong guy
like that he was luck on the Sasuke then
he was you know bisexual male bisexual
right yeah I get it
anyway but I called that guy and he'd
never returned my call and then I tried
again two months later he had changed
his number oh so like he might have had
a wife to I don't really need a lifelong
guy he had a lifelong dude that's
sculptures of [ __ ] oh yeah my dad was a
you know he would also make sculptures I
got a stone he worked with granite like
he'd moved like giant those are big
dicks on the giant oysters she makes a
giant dick no like okay there was the
dick was emphasized in all the
sculptures no in these other like ones
in the house there were and I remember
saying to his wife I'm like they were
saying like how he's such a unique guy I
go he was like tortured you don't think
he was tortured because I did see all
these sculptures had like four heads and
there were four kids and there were like
tons of them everywhere of like
everything was in fours and then he had
his own apartment because he lives
separate from his wife because her son
moved home at like 50 and he's like I'm
not living with a fifty year old kid
maybe yeah and at his place there was
like in his closet it was just like a
bureau and they were like four little
dolls on it everywhere he was tortured
so I said to them after it's like I
looked at my my dad's wife and her
friend and they're like he was such an
interesting artist and had such a cool
perspective and I go he was tortured
what are you talking about I go he was
tormented they can't express it too hard
and I they go what do you mean now they
haven't seen me in 25 years and I'm in
this kitchen and I just explode I go
look
[ __ ] just for Barbie head doll
stacked on top of a baseball you don't
think that's something and they're like
well I don't know and then like I like
walked in the roamers for kids four of
us yeah I walked in the other room and
his wife like followed me in and she's
just like she was just like kind of
standing there with me and I go you
don't think he was tormented all like
you don't see it should I just never
thought of it like that I go that's a
penis with a fishhook through it you
don't think that's something Wow she's
just like kind of like didn't know what
to do and I'm quick she can't process it
with a fin then did they knew that he
was bisexual did you bring it to him no
she came to me and were like listen
here's what's going on do my research
okay this yeah no I think she knew my
aunt told me who I also hadn't seen in
25 years and like I end up like really
connecting with her but then my dad
lives separate so I went to his house
which was like totally rundown and like
I stood where like all the EMT wrappings
were and everything like where he died
essentially did he die from well I think
he had a heart attack they don't know
like because he had a heart attack but
he banged his head on a radiator on the
way down so they don't know like what it
was and they didn't do an autopsy and so
like while I was standing there was like
it was an old school house this guy
upstairs lived and he came down he's
like wow and I'm like oh hey and he goes
oh can I help you I'm like I know norm
you know norm and he goes oh yeah oh
yeah he was my dad and he goes I didn't
know he had any kids and I was like you
[ __ ] and he was like yeah it was
a lot I know but I was just like you
know like so many people go through so
much stuff and his comedians if we're
have the ability to make light of things
that are like hurtful you know what I
mean we we can reach other people out
there that don't have the capability to
even deal with it and they will feel
better and feel more secure in their
life what you gave you had compassion
for your father
I mean you can look at him like the way
I did like Roger I can't understand it I
can't excuse it yeah and then you then
you go he was probably a bisexual or gay
man who was tortured and didn't get
enough yeah whatever I say whatever yeah
yeah but I mean yeah I mean that's a bad
is it very very forgiving way to look at
it
and helps you with closures you know
what's interesting is I have some
friends who they had awful dads and then
they're like super that's like the best
dads I know have their friends we had
awful dads and they're exactly like them
they're horrible people yeah well it's
not bad people they're just bad dads
never around was on the road never out
with the kids just shitty just shitty
dads yeah you got to find it you know
it's it's not the easiest thing in the
world to be a good dad like you take it
for granted when you see people who have
great dads you like dude your dad's
amazing and you just don't realize until
you're in it it'll realize how much goes
into parenthood yeah yeah and the
boredom sometimes I've sitting there
while they do things that you don't even
want to be involved just sitting through
a song recital or or a play rehearsal
where they're all terrible because
they're five and but they're so excited
wrap it up sweetie
yeah thanks goes daddies borders oh yeah
but you do it yeah yeah yeah like I
called my dad the other day when I took
my son to Disneyland for the first time
like hold up cuz he would take us in you
know we didn't come from ton of money
take us every summer come on cloud a
house or so our summer vacation was in
Venice I kind of grew up in Venice every
summer Venice here Venice California I
always forget that yeah so my dad would
take us to Disneyland again we didn't
cut we know it's not Scrooge McDuck
we're playing private over here like the
gallons when we went to Disneyland how
expensive everything was I call my dad
like hold up was it this close when he
took his he's like not far off like it
wasn't cheap man yeah I don't appreciate
like back then what you used to do for
us man yeah nuts
yeah such a hassle hassle I've been like
we used to get my mom [ __ ] for like what
we did because we'd have a lot of money
and she was a single mom but now I'm
like have a total different appreciation
because I'll be home with just the two
kids solo when she was home at 4:20 and
imagine that's that's incredible man
imagine at 27 and my mom's whole deal
was no cable we went to the symphony we
went to musicals we went to that my mom
worked in the ballet ballet everyone had
to play an instrument ever had to play a
sport everyone had to do Boy Scouts or
Girl Scouts see that says are two more
about all the hey you deserve some sort
of [ __ ] medal yeah cuz I'll be with
my son you couldn't kick him
couldn't cook a meatball you know I mean
couldn't coffee boy raise four kids yes
but if you've been around with your kid
for just two days and just one kid it's
a beast yeah imagine for my mom if she
was a very she spit in my face when I
told us to cry on his podcast like my
mom spit in my face one time and he was
like what and I started telling the
story and he's like are you doing that
onstage and then I'm like I don't know
how do I even make that funny so then
like last night I was like I went
onstage and I'm like I start talking
about the stuff I'm talking about now
I'm like you have been spit in the face
by your mom yeah you really don't
probably have perspective on what's
going on so like she was like this super
artistic sense of womb but the same time
she had to be the dad you know me yeah
and if you're gonna raise two boys and
keep them in line every now and then you
had to drop the hammer you know [ __ ] you
don't spin some faces spin your boys
well because when boys get to be about
15 and they're stronger than their mom
they're not hearing a peep unless mom
brings a hammer down yeah that's clearly
rebel yeah I heard a Henner Gracie pitch
in my agent Todd Feldman on why he need
start doing jujitsu because his sons
doing jujitsu a lot and he's like five
and he's like because when he's 12 he's
gonna be able to beat you up if you're
gonna talk back to him he's gonna be
able to strangle you that's not like I
need start jujitsu yeah I was like oh
that's problem yeah that's funny
well good luck let's do some current
events get some Christian sure do all
right the first one is Roy price the
head studio guy form Amazon can't see
[ __ ] yeah let me do that because they
can't sorry I'm saying go ahead ahead of
Amazon he had to resign because of
sexual harassment allegations but what
happened was is a little weird if it
Scrolls down as I'm so Issa Hackett
she's a producer for one of the shows on
Amazon yeah and she she accuses him of
going hold on a sec this is going real
slow
alright so she didn't cues him of saying
some jokes inside a cab
her her father's last name is dick then
the show is I love dick yeah so he made
a comment saying like you're gonna love
my tea load my dick yes I'm like
some something like anything okay she's
gonna that's why you got fired yes
she's gay she lives with a woman she has
kids and it says so again these are
sexual harassment allegations we should
always keep that in mind too I think we
lost his job and so so that's a huge
thing to lose your job so you ask
yourself is that sexual harassment was
he joking in the cab does he deserve no
no that's the biggest thing does he
deserve to lose his job his over-ear
built his whole life on and be publicly
shamed over that I don't think so but I
wasn't there but no glide over j1 lose
jobber
um I here's my whole problem with all
this you made a show called I love dick
first of all you know what I mean so
it's like I feel like there's this fine
line between how do you have equality
when I could joke with you about
something
but I like a guy but I couldn't a woman
isn't that equality we're saying like I
could joke with a woman about it but at
the same time the thing that we don't
really take into account is for years
women have been like pushed down like
with like sexual jokes all time to make
him feel like less than like they
weren't equal to the man above yeah my
wife's in a business a man's world in
her business and she's told me how many
different times dudes have like said
[ __ ] to her and like they try to like
hold you down with like sexual ideas
like like cuz you know the idea of sex
is a man goes into a woman you know what
I mean so I think I find what is more to
the story than this guys because I think
because from what I read about this
story she had he had it had been going
on I think for a while and he resigned
he was not fired so that's like always
like a flag you know I mean and I get
he's worked his ass up but I mean who
knows look at her too good knowing him
resigning is a little bit of a red flag
because usually they might have given
him a chance to reside so that he would
get point severance package true so
there are lots of cool or sometimes they
resign before the [ __ ] comes out we
could go deeper remember that Jaime
maybe Jaime Jaime Horowitz he hired that
lawyer for yes we said there was gonna
be more of the story that came out
nothing nothing yes why I'm fired he he
I think he he he got fired I believe he
got fired yeah so so for me what I worry
about is
days you can be accused of sexual
harassment and it can be innocuous it
can be great dress it can be whatever
and you might be flirtatious screwed and
you're you're in yes this is not there
is a difference between that and a pig
like Harvey Weinstein correct right who
is a [ __ ] scumbag there is a
difference that we have to draw the
distinction otherwise what happens is we
create resentment we create it's it's
it's terrible you're ruining people's
live well what line of work is your wife
in J jewelry Xin jewelry sales she's in
sales but she's worked like big
companies you know but like I was on an
interview this morning for a staff job
for writing and the EP both EPS are
women and I'm in there and even when I'm
like talking like pitching like joke
ideas even though I know the context of
the show can get blue and sexual I was
like certain things I'm like how much
can I say right now because you might
say the wrong even though in a writers
room you could maybe pitch that idea
because it's happened in the context of
show but in this meeting I'm like I
don't this is not like the answer how we
become puritanical now could we become
humorless and sex and now you're
censoring yourself yeah and your censor
yeah but I was just trying to be my hair
to it I know yes yes jokes I think sex
jokes are there's a difference Thanks so
when you flirt there's there's watch
there's like there's the guy who goes I
want to [ __ ] you and then there's a guy
who goes flirt the guy goes he goes
you're so hot I just lost feeling in my
legs I'm weak you know I mean there's a
there's almost like one is on your heels
the other words on your [ __ ] toes so
I think that there's as human beings you
know your body language context and all
is so important of course um we've also
changed in society of like even with
kids like like the things I talked about
like taking his head or like when I tell
people like yeah like we're gonna are
you will you spank your kids versus what
people did we've changed so much that
now like you know so here's what here's
the biggest problem and I know this
happened to people that I know you can
make a joke with a group of people the
woman go my buddy works with children
and he's the best person I know and he
made he didn't even say anything and he
said something about a dress woman that
I feel uncomfortable and she ran and she
has a history of this and told her
superior my buddy was put on suspension
for nine months
until they did the investigation now
when they didn't the investigation she
was totally discredited because he heard
a female lawyer who [ __ ] like it was
unbelievable but it took nine months and
this is what's happening so the pendulum
has swung in some ways is wrong way can
do we have time for me to tell you
something
four years ago I was up for a TV show
and the two creators were women and they
brought me in and in the in the audition
I murdered right and one of them was
going like shut the [ __ ] up shut up shut
up because I was so funny
yeah and I'm like oh we're getting along
I was gonna test for it I got on a phone
call with the director they had the
director call me the three of us had a
conference call where they one of the
direction to go
you're like sizzler I got to the I get
to the callback they send the casting
director home from my audition everyone
went first then me I was in for an hour
I didn't get it
they felt so bad they told my manager we
want to call Jay and tell him like we
felt so bad they never called they gave
they I changed my voicemail to make a
joke towards them told my manager I'm
making a joke towards them who was also
a woman their manager was a woman they
never called my manager told me that I
said they never called she goes home and
tell him to call you right now I didn't
save the voicemail so they go there was
no message
so the chick my managers just call them
I called them and left a version of that
same outgoing message on their voicemail
their producers called me they took it
as a threat I got I didn't get the part
I was also have a general set up in that
production company they shut it down my
manager stopped working for me they
didn't defend me I left the management
company and ultimately I got like
blue-balled Morris you know blackballed
blue-ball too though am i right that's
what like and then it turned into this
thing and these these two people have
had two TV shows what a bummer and and I
like no one stepped up for me they all
just like took it the wrong way and I
was just like I cannot believe that
happened that was four years ago and I
was like I was like peaking at that
point so much stuff was going on and
then that happened like I had a
development deal in the work somewhere
else all the navigation and then so then
I said to my manager can I just call
them and they go
she said no they don't want to talk to
you and I go how about I send an email
and she was let me check with their
manager
I had to wait for the manager to okay it
and she said no they don't want even
need an email from you so I wrote this
beautiful letter I said to my manager
I'm like read it if you like it send it
to theirs if she likes it everyone said
what an amazing letter and two weeks
later one of them reached out and said
we accept Jay's apology yes Jesus just
crazy guys well I'm just telling you
like that was four years ago feel bad
yeah so it's like you know you can I was
only joking that hard because they were
joking that hard you know I mean they I
was in an audition and you're telling me
shut the [ __ ] up how was that the trust
tree there were the circle of trust
anyway man will show this we're gonna
see a lot of this so I don't know I just
want to show you her picture real quick
if you guys don't know what she looks
like
this is Issa the one that's making the
allegations and this is his fiancee that
she now left them or called off their
wedding ever since this happened oh he
called off the one because of this yeah
that seems like it might be a little
more serious it's got to be serious
you're not gonna call for a wedding if
you made a dick joke in the yes like
something there's a little more
something serious him resigning her
being that hot and just dipping out he's
also riches so if you're just gonna dip
out on this sprite some more serious
[ __ ] he's been suspended indefinitely
that was for the this before yeah I'm
just showing in this picture so you can
see is this chick man how crazy do this
you this guy I don't like your life
isn't a lot of vision isn't this a lot
of the [ __ ] to like you're guilty you're
guilty just by accusation of proven
innocent yeah [ __ ] man it's a different
game these days with everything you're
guilty into you're proven in this then
terrible what else you got chin alright
one of your favorite guests here Kevin
Smith I love Kevin yeah alright he's
gonna you know he used to work with
Weinstein a lot yeah in the day he and
why seemed like kind of like invested in
him gave him money all that stuff to
help him get up get up in the directing
business since this all came out there's
allegations of sexual harassment and all
that stuff he feels guilty he feels
guilty with all the movies he's made
with Weinstein he feels like it's dirty
money or whatever so he's giving all the
residuals
all the residual checks he gets from
those movies to this thing called
women's women in the film
Guymon and he's gonna give $2,000 a
month for the rest of his life to that
same organization oh wow all right how
how creamy I mean I love chemistry shots
chemistry so how creepy is it when you
look at Harvey Weinstein now and to
think about the [ __ ] he did with those
women
he just says could you get any more
hideous I mean he's not an attract oh
god you know what I really have a my
main problem is is that in this business
we grandi eyes and put these people on a
pedestal so that it's been like for so
long everything just escapes and lets
things go and you're like oh whatever
and then all sudden something comes out
and like how could this happen you like
what are you talking about like everyone
kind of knew looking about I mean around
the what like I knew I was talking with
other agents I won't say the name
they're like oh we are we've heard
stories for you yeah it's like in in LA
like everyone knew this was a guy was a
terrible person and even even fans out
there they just want people to be famous
they just want to have a taste of Fame
and they don't care about who these the
character of people well there's also
nothing you can do about it sometimes so
so so okay the guy's a scumbag but what
kind of soso if you were to say to the
average American there's a producer in
Hollywood as a scumbag but he makes
great movies Hollywood's always had a
scummy reputation Hollywood's always had
a very subversive relation like oh you
mean there's a casting couch the oldest
story in the world so if you're a young
girl and you're going to Hollywood
you know the stories are rife with
stories about you know you're gonna help
you there's a joke after joke after joke
yeah so it's not surprising to anybody
what I think is surprising is the extent
to which and how far heat this guy was
willing to go yeah well we've had an
obvious problem but more importantly I
think what makes people really discuss
it isn't even the way he looks it's more
that he would do this and pressure peep
women yeah into like their whole careers
on the line and he would threaten you
with ruination yeah you know ya know
trust me I do not ruin your career with
her second yeah with a phone call and he
obviously would do that on top of the
fact that when you did threaten to bring
allegations he had the best lawyers in
the [ __ ] world
yeah and so all of a sudden you
or somebody who works once in a while
the most powerful man in Hollywood goes
oh really
I have five lawyers that'll destroy you
on top of the financial settled a ton
eight or not yeah and they also have
people who are called fixers and they
show up and they show up and they have
coffee with you with a folder and they
go here's all the stuff we have on you
you heard or read that guy had and see
what happens and you go oh Jesus Christ
I'm fighting a machine
yeah for sure no I know it's horrible so
when they say that Gweneth Paltrow kept
her mouth shut no you don't know what
it's like to be a 22 year old girl I
don't give a [ __ ] who your parents are
when you got Harvey Weinstein then you
just keep your [ __ ] mouth shut
because you can't fight it yeah you
can't fight it yeah you know what else
you get Jim this one Gordon Hayward you
see this carry on you know the the
history behind him right so he just got
signed to the Celtics so gorgeous you
want me to David so Gordon Hayward is a
beast he played in Utah he just got used
a huge free agent signing with the four
years 128 million dollars hey probably
the best-looking white dude in the
league like handsome dude baller
it was the Celtics and the Cavs supposed
to be in the finals for the East this
year literally right what is in it first
first quarter most your new signing they
said Oh Boston everyone's excited go and
play it chin go and play a tune he's
right here
watch his leg so we got a a gaming
tournament next door it's sucking out
the Wi-Fi so oh god he has an Anderson
Silva break just I mean JMO oh god
dammit not only I don't see it again
Celtics fans possums like goose oh it
was awful I'll tell you right now we'll
still be in the Eastern Conference 500
percent these sucks balls well and we
have a stud team you know I mean and we
have the best coach in the well top
three coach in the NBA right young
chance you know he was hey which coach
and college I sure I know it all brother
I don't know oh I know everything about
sports there we go but when I saw this I
was bummed for hey we're because I think
you saw dude and I'm stoked
but having Kyrie and we have a great
bench and we do we have that do we we
drafted last year who played in Europe
who now came back I wrote this video
game right here NBA 2k you did yeah I
did this year I was one of the writers
on it yeah yeah I know yeah I'm dead
serious
damn son yeah I used to also be the Fox
robot for NFL really used to tweet as
the Fox robot and like would blog for
the NFL for their you know your [ __ ] I
know everything about sports head it's
my Pat like when we were kids there was
no ESPN I mean there was but we didn't
have it I would just get up get Boston
Globe and I read box scores I'm still a
box score junkie every I'll tell you I
mean I where's my lair on the NFL tell
you any stat right now whose nature
study team oh [ __ ] you grew up
Massachusetts the South's the Pats the
bees and the Seas yeah the Sox yeah yeah
man that was a bummer I just feel bad
but I think we're gonna be okay
yeah I feel bad we also lost Jae Crowder
in the deal for Irving and Jae Crowder
would have been perfect and he was
awesome last year and he's got a low cap
and he makes you know doesn't make a ton
of money which would have been awesome
good whatever you know because if he had
known you were this much of a sports
head you guys talk sports win this for
action I have to censor myself like I'm
Harvey wants um who wait who your team's
my team's Oh in what sport I'm from
Denver son so the Broncos love the
Broncos yeah yeah sure sure not the
biggest Nuggets fan there all right I
like more players I know let's go you
knees to with the RIT with the rainbow
on it it will be free didn't you play
over there yeah they have to change it
up though then baseball I'm not the big
again I like more players and teams yeah
Rockies sorry so who's your player it
just I mean I like a bunch I could
obviously even judge killing it right
now yeah he's alright well you're
bossing Betsy and I can't let goes trash
how about the I bet the the World Series
gonna be Dodgers Yankees I mean if the
Yankees makes the World Series with that
I'm shocked that they've gone as far as
they have Astros man that lineup is
Tommy Bobby gorgeous yeah and they built
up out of nothing man they suck for so
long either way how good it would be for
if it's la verse New York yeah that's
what mobis like come on of course they
are and of course yeah but to this I saw
this you're bringing up and get there
this is tweet after hey how about skip
bayless like you're just the biggest
he's just a tool you don't say like he's
just a [ __ ] tool he's a he's on the
Fox wart shows and so look he Hayward
gets hurt no one let's see a guy
especially like that not like a you know
like a roll bangle I think your your
[ __ ] leg is backwards it's not good
he just signed it sucks
he puts if Gorn Hayward is gone maybe
for the season with bronze path to
losing six finals gets even easier he's
just a boy
what does that mean he basically he's a
LeBron hater yeah he's ripping on LeBron
at the expense of Gordon Hayward getting
hurt but here's the biggest problem
everyone just roasted him the like Eve
NBA players other professional athletes
like your piece of sh you're a clown for
that tweet after man gets hurt with the
potential career ending injury bigger
than life bigger than basketball DeMar
DeRozan let me just say this dude here's
the bigger problem the bigger problem is
ESPN keeps giving an outlet to guys like
Skip Bayless not ESPN labium Fox wursten
Skip Bayless used to be untrue whenever
that stupid show were he'd always his
stupid against Stephen a Smith yeah who
like why do we want to hear your
perspective of anything but basketball
dude anything you know what I mean
that's what we keep giving and then
who's a Lavar ball you know that dallof
are they give him more shine and it's
like stop it
it's strange stop giving the shine it's
what they want the ratings it's the same
[ __ ] with like the Harvey Weinstein prom
whatever is gonna make the ultimate
dollar they don't give a [ __ ] here's
that I agree but skip bayless they're
not getting rings so what what I don't
what the show is called malfunction
ratings are yeah well that's just horse
doesn't get any ratings
I know Burt's one you even know where it
is on your box no idea but you know he's
not getting ratings either so he turns
it stroll you know how crazy this skip
bayless is so insecure he had multiple
fake accounts that he would log on to
himself and defend haters against them
and then he [ __ ] up one time in log on
accidentally his real cameras and defend
himself and then people like God your
fake accounts that's him if you had to
apologize
he's a loser oh yeah he's a loser too
what else get chin all right let's wait
for this thing to load all right so the
Redford Township Police Department in
Michigan they put out this thing on
their Facebook about a guy that's wanted
for a bunch of misdemeanor warrants
he needs some chapstick for God's it
looks pretty big so they did that on
their Facebook page and he actually
replied to it
his name is Champaign Torino and he says
yeah I'm not worried about it if your
next post gets a thousand shares I'll
turn myself in along with a dozen donuts
and that's a promise and I'll pick up
every piece of litter all around your
public schools let's see if you can get
those shares you just trying to increase
his followers on it go I he has a
warrant for his arrest and then the the
township police department got a bunch
of shares like four thousand shares so
he literally turned himself in with
doughnuts with doughnuts Wow
what did he do though exactly a bunch of
misdemeanor warrants just probably bunch
of stuff that you didn't pay off tickets
no just not he's just trying to get
followers pisser those are some legit
glazed doughnuts store bought though you
know I didn't go to a bakery for that
never had sidecar doughnuts in Santa
Monica no I never actually had them what
they're doing it'll where are they
simple though I don't want thing that I
got Captain Crunch on it yeah I know
[ __ ] with that either no they got a
nice glazed twist there your sim and
sugar one talked a cake doughnut yes
okay they have cake they have cake and
they have the other they've the rise the
puffy I like it I prefer cake I love a
cake donut man you'd like their donut
holes man yeah well let me just say what
do you mean I think this is fun to be
honest with me do it he's like hey why
don't we make this fun like I'll come in
um bring doughnuts no they're gonna get
caught so why not turn yeah he's like I
last night trying to [ __ ] run from it
listen you get up 4,000 shares on
Facebook up a come with donuts and they
tagged him I love that they tagged him
in the post get a hashtag going on that
- an attack 12d well did you ever see
did you ever see the the guy who got he
went to prison or I'm sorry jail for
something his mug shot and he's just
this he's a convict he's just this died
people yeah yeah
blue piercing blue eyes you know
light-skinned african-american dude like
gorgeous and the mugshot comes out and
everyone's like what the [ __ ] it blows
up like figure out miles and retweet he
gets out of prison and he's a
straight-up model now yeah like gorgeous
Bobby contract [ __ ] I do your sign me
back any trouble or no no he's a
straight-up model oh yeah his girlfriend
he is like famous girl now awesome [ __ ]
man okay so ever you get out there again
what no one cares no one cares they only
care about the almighty dollar it's like
I was watching something the other day
and they had Ray Lewis talking about the
the state of the NFL in like do we does
everyone just forget Ray Lewis killed a
guy no one cares he [ __ ] killed a guy
and now we're asking this guy for advice
on how to have a legit happy all the guy
do you know Michael Vick is a has a show
now on Fox on [ __ ] he's part of the Fox
gameday crew listen to me I'm a believer
in second chances
and I was like how much they screw they
hung that man yeah
they laid it right didn't he went to
jail did he served his time and that's
the came back out old early stuff for
dogs played played practice changed sure
did so he there is redemption trust me I
always like Michael Vick I'm saying not
offend the NFL just was like you know
what we're gonna nope
he nobody wants him we'll throw him out
and now that he comes back the sports
robe like okay you know I mean I just
think find it weird two times they're
like this Sunday Fox is back and it
shows Colin coward
it shows whoever and then you know Jim
Brown and then it shows Michael then
Michael Vick it's not me it's just like
good I had to double check it's like
that me too if I been happy feeling just
like why'd it I think America forgave
him it's really I think I mean I think
it you know you we have to we you
weren't a fan of his play or us fan of
his play I don't forgive I don't mmm I
don't I don't forgive him I I think you
give anything to like the upbringing he
where he grew up Virginia that
dogfighting is the thing that's what I'm
saying that's why I mean like some of
these guys can come from a certain
place you know what I mean it's huge
down there it's like you grew up with it
doesn't mean it's right when you become
a grown man you have 50 million dollars
in a bank and you're killing us and dogs
well I guess he had a yeah yeah I have
pit bulls I mean I've always had him
some yeah it's tough you know we we know
it's not the right thing to do I don't
know [ __ ] you're right that's a whole
excuse you also have how much money
fifty million and why do you need a
legal thing why do you need a legal
dogfighting ring but you saw that's
where you come from I don't give a [ __ ]
so I've there's there's famous rappers
basketball players NFL players that come
from gangs they're not still involved in
gang violence some are not really
remember back when like they were doing
gang signs on the sidelines back what
was that like twelve years ago I mean
long I mean look they're still not we're
not rolling with the course of salt on a
racing horse racing got the ugly side of
dog racing and horse racing yeah after
about three years a lot of those dogs
most of those dogs are put down yeah
most and what that's what people realize
they got a two year three year life span
yeah and racehorses it's not a pretty
ending for them either
yeah cause by the time I think they're
three before you know some of them get
sent off to places but a lot of them
don't so the dogs a little different
than horse right yeah for sure
I'm not look there's darts I'm not
defending the man I love any of it what
I'm saying is that what I'm saying is
that it's interesting to me it is
surprising that America has a love
affair with dogs something about the way
he handled it
people forgave him and you know have
they though what do you mean forgave
unlike you most people have I mean I
would say the marketplace has I say the
marketplace has yeah you know what I
mean and and football's not selling
jerseys or anything played though he
played for a la Villette I mean like
said Ray low-skill guy puts he'll burst
shot himself
if inter Hernandez got off they would
let him play it's just about it's about
winning games that doesn't mean yeah or
gave them money Hardy for the Dallas
Cowboys had I mean he did time in prison
for domestic violence he came out again
to domestic violence you know they did
they signed him
oh yeah and now he's doing MMA right
yeah has this first fight like soon yeah
interesting
good luck fighting that monster what
else you got gin all right got one more
champagne Torino it's hilarious though
this is the first time a chimp has been
observed eating another chimp by size
this is what it says the first time it's
been observed I can I could I could you
- but Chimpy another chimp yeah feed
monkeys but actually I know oh you're
saying eat its own kind is cannibal I
read chamber goodall's book they did the
chimps yeah with you James have video of
it no we don't have the video cuz chimps
will cuz they're good yeah
in the wild chimpanzees will get mad at
another chimp rip it they take their
baby and eat their baby in front of the
mom and this is in the same thing what's
this what's going on with this anyway
there is a pregnant Channel it just gave
birth seconds later the this chimp named
Darwin ran up to it grabbed it yeah took
it to a tree and just ate it Fox 1% that
happens is the first video no-one's
captured video of it well there's video
of a pregnant female and the chimps are
crowding around hers they want to eat
her [ __ ] baby then there's another
video I've seen of the pregnancy a bit
of a female with her baby and the other
women are like that thing looks
delicious and they start chasing her up
the tree but she's freaking out chimps
are no joke this was in Newsweek it said
it was the very first ever observed
cannibalism weird man that's some dark
[ __ ] in the monkey world yeah mm-hmm
just shows you everyone has the problems
am i right you know what Brennan monk
you're here right
sometimes they're not monkeys they're
Apes so they're even closer to us though
you know I'm saying guys anything ya
know sometimes what else you got chin
that's it
boom got myself a dropping we do a
little dropping knowledge here oh yeah
I'm gonna drop I'm gonna drop a very
fancy name I want you to think about
what it is do you guys know about the
sign oh Ram dudas elegans Brennan do you
know about sino
Ram did Asst elegans I don't do worm
you know why I'm bringing up a worm
mmm-hmm cuz it's a good way to lose
weight cuz [ __ ] bear heard of that
before you go on before you drop this
[ __ ] knowledge yeah have you heard of
models swung tapeworms to lose weight
yes carry on I think it's a myth though
it's definitely not watch the whole
documentary Oh carry on well the this
worm the sign Oh
Ram it Ram did us know I gotta write it
down yeah is a warm and scientists have
succeeded in extending its life by two
times so usually they die and scientists
have figured out a way to keep it alive
twice as long because they're starting
to figure out how cells degenerate and
there's something called the Gilgamesh
project do you know the story about
Gilgamesh everybody the oldest epic
Gilgamesh sits by his best friend dinky
doos body he's dead
he sees a worm coming out his nostril he
freaks out he goes I'm gonna defeat
death and he goes and tries to find the
elixir do you know to try to stop from
being you know from dying at the end the
gods say it can't happen okay you have
to accept your limitations
can I please break for you the
difference between now today and the
Scientific Revolution as it came before
us history philosophy and science was
all about how to come to terms with
death we are now in an age where we are
literally
trying to defeat death so that people
will be what's the word not immortal but
a mortal which means we will stay alive
as long as you really need to stay alive
and that is a reality as we learn not
only how to cure diseases but also how
to stop the degeneration of the cell and
there's something called the Gilgamesh
project where they are [ __ ] really
working on that and with this worm and
with tissue generation and they're kind
of coming up with a bionic blood dope a
bionic and blood dope with young people
well they're coming up with a bionic
immune system so that you'll have
thousands of nanobots that go through
your body and keep arteries unclogged
kill cancer cell be devilish it comes up
actually actually they believe by 2050
according to serious scholars in science
maybe who studies 2050 you think you
35 years now [ __ ] that's 33
years now
83 would you run at those I'm super
happening the candle both excuse me sir
you think you at 83 yeah how dare you
the point is I [ __ ] dying everybody
yeah it's not gonna be cheaper so I
better start a little ah sergeant those
bots aren't gonna be cheap now they're
not gonna be cheap that's why we got to
keep this podcast go home bro hey I do
want to say I also it's a band the
Gilgamesh project and I saw them at the
Viper Room recently and they were
[ __ ] awesome yeah yeah I don't know
if I want to live that long holy [ __ ]
now hundred and you know making that
[ __ ] living I'd like to live the two
hundo would you yeah no that's all my
back feels yeah the best look how your
skin looks how you
oh they're figuring all that [ __ ] out
works up to you gotta keep me there
figuring all that out yeah Jay we
appreciate coming on man hey you guys
especially you have said this Friday
this Friday where can they give it a
Larson calm be calm and your blast
what's your Instagram I like Jay Larson
to come back I'm all of it we're gonna
blast out on our in my man you the best
with you come see me in that Calgary
this goddamn we got a yacht Young Jeezy
ox-head called yucky yucky yucky huh
keys yes all right go see Colin Calgary
a new eye a bunch of dates an ounce but
we just added buffalo in December going
to Buffalo take master Buffalo doing it
brother I'm going to Buffalo oh you
sound a direct flight at night or how
many dozen doing weekend you're doing
all weekend long weekend in Buffalo Wow
doing weekend Buffalo weekend Nashville
Wow I know no son I'm not mad at
Nashville I love natural being win
December December cool you got fun might
die huh
it'll be fine it's helium's a great club
they run a great operation there Jimmy
good tickets on sale now
tea fat cake on for Brian and myself go
get Jay Larson do special this Friday we
love you guys this is the fun kid we're
out